I mean I wish I I wish I wasn't like
this I wish I could wake up every day
we're in the same hey how about this how
about this I'm at the [ __ ] Rams game
a guy goes yo I saw you last night at
the Comedy Store
everybody looks at me there guy like
that and then punch people who recognize
me the guy and he's like four rows up
still because you swear to god he goes
like this he goes he goes I love it I
couldn't believe it I ran away I was
like god damn it it's hilarious it was
so funny and he's right I'm going to eat
shot st. edwen the same thing back then
man no make sides my underwear I'm
laying it up on the same day no I please
playing you just yeah no just a bummer I
keep my whistle clean oh yeah we call
see him just to get in you're waiting in
a giant did I tell you when I want to
hump compat with my girl my family the
line long I finally the plays ago do do
my girl goes please just be quiet just
I'm freaked out like yeah I've been
working all day I don't want to sit in
lines Fallon plays ago do do what's
gonna take get in there I'll give you
$100 you guys why I went that's why $700
that man there goes doesn't work like
that buddy he said that hey you [ __ ]
give you a hundred bucks down for the
punk I respect it well I iced it when
there was a line my father there was
literally a line at LaGuardia or it was
a JFK we were me and 11 family members
11 now the poems we're going to
Dominican Republic and it was it was
Christmastime so the line was and my dad
who is a rule follower from Wisconsin
and a good man is standing all the way
in the back of the line and I go I if I
do this I'm gonna die I don't I don't
recommend this this is [ __ ] this is
shitty of me but I'm from New York man
identify more with you Sicilian side so
I go with my father I go you how much
cash you have him he goes what I go how
much cash he always has cash he goes
well I don't know I don't go give me a
hundred bucks he goes what are you gonna
do I go I'm gonna get us out of here oh
and he goes no no give me a hundred
dollars right now
I walked to the guy go hey bro can I ask
you a quick question I am a hundred
dollars now can I get my eleven family
members like ahead of this line agreed
he goes come with me
that was it - come with me they were
like I just am [ __ ] yeah everybody don't
gots do me you gots to well it's like
dizzy and the lines are so long I looked
at I'm like how much is how much the VIP
stuff and you go through I'm like I mean
yeah yeah that's where my that's where
money if you have crazy money which I
don't have but if you have crazy money
like a friend of mine who was they
screwed up something and he was in this
insane line and they're gonna wait and
it was gonna be a day before they got
flying yeah my friend goes I'm gonna get
a private jet that's what that's real
money I'm gonna get her but that's
$54,000 hey worth it how about so it's
well Dyke mange suffers from anger issue
sees way better now he's a kid is a
that's gonna therapy really all awful
but we are in line in in Texas at a BBQ
place and we've kind of a long line
we're waiting there
I can see Jake you know Jays get a
little sweaty he's like this thing
seemed getting like irritable but I it
was a long line as a kite we don't know
anyone else waiting line away and I see
Jay just kind of like they like this and
then we find you to the front and he's
like got it so exactly like me too we
get there and the people in front was
going now the brisket how is dude there
for 15 minutes
oh my god 50 minutes and we've been
waitin live for 50 minutes they're 15
going through all the everything and you
can tell the even the guy working
there's like yeah so you I gotta get I
got her you three all right hold on now
if we get this and it's the only time it
flares up god he's in line that's how
rude
oh you dummy oh do move it on you I even
went like this I went whatever if you
will take I'll pay for theirs just let
let us go forward I'll pay for whatever
the [ __ ] they're getting just let us go
with you we're not a time crunch I'm
like please just let us go and you're
hungry I saw Jay you in the meat sweats
and they got there in sweats
yeah and he's all white so that his neck
started get all red yeah yeah he's like
come back out man split he's okay oh and
he's every bit of 235 240 so a woman
in argentina tried smuggling nine pounds
of weed through an airport and she got
caught this is the photo that they put
unbelievable that's hilarious
oh yeah she thought she was gonna get
away you don't look pregnant no it looks
so outlandish and what the the TSA was
like all right well yeah it's just it's
clearly she's hiding something so she
didn't get very far
hilarious I scan you - all right so this
is you don't need a scan you just kind
of like no we can't go through the skin
if you're pregnant because the radio mom
but they're ladies what are you doing
like the hair long dude are we recording
cats like your hair dude Thanks I mean
you look Italian is house what the
people are saying do me a favor gorgeous
I look like just awful my name is my
name is Fabrice your vision of a time
just - can you good acts on Saturday my
name is ELISA me
my name is fib - I like the way the dick
tail no don't say that
no where's the dick take my name my name
is a phablet you it's my wife
say my name is Fabrizio I'm a Fabrizio
my name my name is Fabrice forbid you
that's not kind of right yeah yeah
almost identical yeah now look at me and
say you're too beautiful for me I'd die
for you I'd die for you yeah yeah yeah
you could be a [ __ ] Italian actor
just soap opera guy dude
aye aye you are you are too beautiful
for me I'd die for you I'd die for you I
[ __ ] your mouth no no no they don't say
that no no or no no no no we're not
doing at a time we're doing i dumping
now we're doing [ __ ] we're doing oh
god dude I'm trying to around mozzarella
mozzarella that's what said
that you as it's a Gish it's a gift it's
a gift